the third wave shows no sign of slowing
down
latest public health england data shows
cases continue to be at their highest
in people in their 20s with a case rate
of 1
155 cases per 100
000 people over the last seven days that
is the highest ever recorded
for any age group with more cases there
are bound to be more contacts and that
shows in new data
a little over 223 000 people who tested
positive in england
were chased up by test and trace to
provide their contacts in the week to
july the 14th
that's the highest number since the 20th
of january
but only 85.6 of them could be reached
the lowest
since the end of last october more than
000 of their close contacts were
identified the highest since january the
20th
but only 90 were reached and told to
self-isolate
it's clear evidence that cases and
contacts are slipping through the net as
the epidemic picks up speed
potential contacts are also identified
through the kovid app
and weekly figures from the nhs show
just under 619
000 people in england and wales were
pinged
in the week to july the 14th that's up
from 521 000 the week before
a rise of almost 17 analysis by sky news
shows that pings are increasing in line
with cases
suggesting it works as expected but the
app
is also disrupting critical businesses
so is it still worth it when it was
first launched last year
six percent of people who were pinged
went on to develop symptoms
in three months it prevented almost six
hundred thousand cases
but that was before the vaccine now more
than sixty nine percent of adults are
double jabbed
and after two doses the fisa jab is 88
effective at preventing symptomatic
disease the astrazeneca vaccine a little
less
so fully jab people who are pinged are
much less likely to develop
kovid and from august the 16th people
who've had both doses will no longer
need to isolate
if they're pinged if they test negative
but the value of the app is already
lower than it was and it's getting lower
as more people are double jabbed
with public confidence waning the
government's determination to stick to
the date
will come under increasing pressure